the Academy nickel fellowship has
enormous significance for me as a
screenwriter and as a governor of the
screenwriters branch of the Academy the
Academy has 17 branches but ours is the
only branch with a dedicated fellowship
that allows us to extend a hand to the
next generation of emerging artists in
our field it's an incredible privilege
the existence of the nickel fellowships
attest to the facts that writing is
foundational to cinema those of us on
the nickel committee believe that the
importance of mentorship in young
Raiders cannot be overstated and I can
really speak for my own haphazard
experience when I broke into the film
business in nineteen eighty i was
completely clueless about the art and
the business of screenwriting i was from
a small town in the south and I went to
New York seeking a way to make movies I
kept my day job there while I was still
trying to teach myself to write at night
and on weekends and I knocked on a lot
of doors in New York looking for a way
into filmmaking after really zero
success two things finally happened some
friends and I put on a small fringe
production of a play that I had written
on off off Broadway in the basement of
the Ansonia hotel and an agent
small-time agent who was working on her
own saw the play and suggested that I
try writing for film when I gave her a
screenplay but I was working on and
somehow she managed to sell it that was
how I got in at the time there was
really very few female screenwriters
working in Hollywood I was so hungry for
a mentor and so keen to try and
understand filmmaking better that I used
to just cold approach film editors at
screenings and so forth and asked if I
could sit in their editing rooms only
one editor gave me permission it was
Susan from key who was cutting
documentaries for the mazal brothers but
it was by this kind of trial and error
that I began to learn the rules and
conventions of cinematic narrative and
how to navigate the film industry what
the nickel fellowship does is open the
door to writers who are working on their
own and looking for a way to enter the
professional world to filmmaking because
the nickel committee and our team of
readers is drawn from every branch of
the Academy
the nickel fellowship actually allows
everyone in the Academy to serve as
mentors for this emerging writers it's a
community effort the Academy nickel
fellowships carries a generous cash
prize which is a huge boost for writer
getting her start when I wrote my first
screenplay I was using a friend's borrow
typewriter so it cash really makes a
difference but perhaps more important
than the prize money is just the simple
acknowledgment by the Academy that we
believe in the work of these writers who
are being honored tonight and we will
back you with all of the resources that
the Academy has to offer this past
weekend the governor's awards the
Academy honored screenwriter jean-claude
carrière with an honorary Oscar kind of
a lifetime achievement award jean-claude
who has elevated screenwriting to the
level of literature through his work on
more than 130 films sat on Saturday that
too often screenwriters go unnoticed and
are like shadows passing through the
history of cinema we want to be sure
that that doesn't happen to these
incredibly talented writers who are
among this year's finalists and winners
over these years the Academy over the
years that the fellowship has been in
existence the Academy has received more
than 130,000 script submissions for the
fellowship that's a lot is replaced the
writers have gone on to win prizes and
accolades around the world and I have to
say that this year's winners have
emerged from a pretty competitive pack
one question I often hear about the
nickel fellowship is who reads all those
scripts well more people than ever now
have to dedicate their time to reviewing
the submissions and making
recommendations this year's crop was
read by more than 200 Academy member
volunteers 45 of them have been one have
one or have been nominated for Academy
Awards during their careers pretty
high-class bunch so i have to say thank
you to them for giving their time
and I want to thank the rest of the
Academy nickel committee who poured over
the finalists scripts and engaged in a
very spirited discussion before we
arrived at this year's list of honorees
I don't think that there is a more
accomplished group of judges anywhere so
with the nickel committee members who
are here tonight please stand
I would like to congratulate last year's
fellows who were able to join us tonight
Frank to John David hedges you guys can
stand up patty Jones Alan Ross Stephanie
Shannon Barbra Stefanski I hope you had
a great fellowship here and I cannot
wait to see your movies we are also
really lucky to have with us tonight
some past fellows who wrote or directed
films that were in release or word
festivals this past year there is life
after the nickel anthony jaswinski here
what Christie Eric eryn krueger who
wrote transformers age of extinction
James modern who directed by the gun and
Rebecca's son and shine who's a writer
producer on the Vampire Diaries
fantastic so before we begin our
readings tonight let's just take a
moment to thank the three casting
directors who gave their time to bring
us an excellent cast we could not have
done this without the help of David
Rubin Bernie Telsey + lure Kennedy and
of course with the help of Dina Michelle
we are really lucky to have a casting
branch now thank you Mary Jane for
feeding us thank you dawn Hudson for
your continual support and now it is my
pleasure to introduce you yeah introduce
to you the host of tonight's ceremony
who is the director of Albert Nobbs the
writer director of mother and child one
of my favorite directors Rodrigo Garcia